Alors, pourquoi 1
liste de la France
insoumise aux élections sénatoriales
en Loire-Atlantique ?
En bref, c'est à cause de personnes qui ont préféré
balayer l'espoir de la NUPES
pour aller plus vite,
tout seul plutôt que plus loin ensemble.
D'abord, 1 p'tit récap.
L'an dernier, en deux-mille-vingt-deux,
la France insoumise,
le parti communiste,
le parti socialiste et les écologistes ont formé la
NUPES. Cette coalition,
a permis d'envoyer cent-cinquante-et-un députés de
gauche à l'Assemblée nationale.
Et surtout, elle a
privé Emmanuel Macron de sa majorité parlementaire.
Par cohérence,
la France insoumise a proposé à ses partenaires de
prolonger cette alliance
lors des élections sénatoriales du 24/09 prochain.
Sur les cent-soixante-dix-huit sièges remis en jeu,
la France insoumise a demandé 1 position éligible.
Et cette position éligible,
elle aurait été dans 1 configuration
où l'alliance
de toutes les gauches aurait permis la conquête
d'un siège sur la droite.
Les parties nationaux
ont refusé
cette logique et on préférait signer des accords
département par département.
Le tout bien sûr sans les insoumis.
Donc en gros,
dans 1 département, ils sont ensemble, à 2 ou à 3,
et dans le département,
d'un côté, ils sont les uns contre les autres.
C'est absolument illisible.
Nous,
nous voulons prolonger l'espoir qu'a créé la noblesse.
C'est pourquoi nous présentons 1
liste qui porte son programme,
celui qui a permis
de gagner le 1ère tour des élections législatives
en deux-mille-vingt-deux.
Moi, je m'appelle Maxime biancin, j'ai 33 ans,
je suis graphiste et j'habite à reuzer.
Je. Suis tête de lisse de la France insoumise
pour les élections sénatoriales
en loir-atlantique.
Vous avez les moyens de changer les choses.
Vos élus vont devoir voter à cette élection.
Intéressez-vous à ce qu'ils votent,
interpellez-les pour qu'ils votent pour
notre liste qui porte le programme de la UPC
et abonnez-vous à nos réseaux sociaux.